hey there guys just wanted to make a
quick video today to talk to you about
this
a hand dynamometer
dynamometer
so this is a device that you can use in
order to measure your grip strength it's
quite simple
you hold the handle there
you apply
force and then it tells you
how much
you managed to squeeze in kilograms or
pounds that's 62.5
not bad so this is just quite a cool
little um tool you can use to measure
your grip strength which is very
important for overall strength and
performance in the gym
also useful for measuring your recovery
as some people say the grip strength
correlates with your
testosterone to cortisol ratio which
blah blah blah has something to do with
recovery i'm not sure about that i think
i managed to find it referenced in one
study but it does make sense that um
your grip strength uh and how that
fluctuates from day to day first thing
in the morning this is might be an
indicator
of
your strength overall and certainly your
central nervous system and your ability
to recruit and use that strength but
whether or not you're using it for that
just for general grip strength and
that is an indicator of overall
improvements in the gym it's just a cool
little gadget uh to use and to see
yourself improve which is always
encouraging and see which type of
training are being most
effective for you so i wanted to show
you that because it's very cheap you can
pick up on amazon um also just as an
example uh that you don't necessarily
need an expensive fitness tracking watch
or device in order to do fitness
tracking fitness tracking is any kind of
measurement and there's all kinds of
cool devices out there to measure all
sorts of different metrics so
um yeah i'm going to talk about a few
different devices in future videos but
if you're interested in testing a grip
strength uh get a dynamometer oh and
also it goes up to i think 80 or maybe
even 100 kilograms so you're probably
not gonna break it and it's quite cool
just as a training tool it's better than
those um grip strength trainers so
yeah pick that up thanks for watching
i'll see you next time